is there a meaning to this thing is
there a meaning to life what is the
meaning of life
i was brought up by a physicist uh and a
physician
they were more or less committed
atheists who had left the church of
scotland
as a protest against sectarianism in
glasgow
and so my sister and i were told from an
early age life was a cosmic accident
and
that was it there was no great meaning
to it
uh
and i i can't really get past that
isn't there beauty to being an accident
at a cosmic scale
yes i wasn't taught to to feel negative
about that and if anything
it was a frivolous
a frivolous insight the whole thing was
a kind of joke
um
and and i think that
atheism isn't really a basis for
ordering a society but
it's
it's
been all right for me
i don't have
a kind of sense of of a missing
religious
faith for me
however there's clearly some embedded
christian ethics in the way
my parents lived and so we were kind of
atheist calvinists
who had kind of deposed god but carried
on behaving as if we were members of the
elect in in a moral universe so
that's kind of um
the state of mind that
i was left in
and
i
i think that
we aren't really around long enough
to claim that our individual lives have
meaning
but what
edmund burke said is true the real
social contract is between the
generations between the dead the living
and the unborn and the meaning of life
is
for me at least
to live in a way that honors the dead
seeks to learn from their accumulated
wisdom because they do still outnumber
us they outnumber the
the living by quite a significant margin
and then
to be mindful of the unborn and our our
responsibility
to them writing books is a way of
communicating with the unborn
it may or may not succeed and probably
won't succeed if my books are never
assigned by work professors in the
future
so what we have to do is more than just
write books and record podcasts
there have to be institutions on 57 now
i realized recently that succession
planning had to be
the main focus of the next 20 years
because
there are things that i really care
about
that i want future generations to have
access to
and
so the meaning of life i do regard as
being intergenerational transfer of
wisdom
ultimately the species will go extinct
at some point
even if we do colonize mars one senses
that
physics will catch up with this
particular organism but it's in the
pretty far distant future and so the
meaning of life is to make sure that for
as long as there are human beings
they are able to
live the kind of fulfilled lives
ethically fulfilled intellectually
fulfilled
emotionally fulfilled lives that
civilization has made possible
it would be easy for us to revert
to the uncivilized world
there's a fantastic book that
that i'm going to
misremember milos is the captive soul
the captive mind rather
um which
has a fantastic passage
he was a
polish intellectual who says americans
can never imagine what it's like
for civilization to be completely
destroyed as it was in poland at the end
of by the end of world war ii to have no
rule of law to have no security of even
person never mind property rights they
can't imagine what that's like and what
it will lead you to do
so one reason for teaching history is to
remind the lucky
generation z members
of california that
that civilization's a thin film and it
can be destroyed remarkably easily
and to preserve civilization is a
tremendous
responsibility that we have it's a huge
responsibility
and we must we must not destroy
ourselves whether it's in the name of of
wokism or the pursuit of the metaverse
preserving civilization and making it
available not just to our kids but to
people we'll never know
generations ahead that's the meaning
and
do so by studying the lessons of history
right not only studying them but then
acting on them
for me the biggest problem is how do we
apply history more effectively it seems
as if our institutions including
government are very very bad at applying
history
lessons of history are learned poorly if
at all analogies are drawn crudely often
the wrong inferences are drawn
one of the big intellectual challenges
for me is how to make history more
useful
and this was the kind of thing that
professors used to hate but really
practically useful so that policymakers
and citizens
can think about the decisions that they
face with
a more historically informed
body of knowledge
whether it's a pandemic the challenge of
climate change what to do about taiwan
i can't think of a better set of
uh of things to know
before you make decisions about those
things than than the things that history
has to offer well i love the discipline
of applied history basically going to
history and saying what
are the
key principles here that are applicable
to the problems of today right and how
can we solve that great philosopher of
history rg collingwood
said in his autobiography which was
published in 1939
that the purpose of history
was to reconstitute past thought
from whatever
surviving remnants there were
and then to juxtapose it
with our own predicament and that's that
juxtaposition of past experience with
present experience that is so important
we don't do that well
uh and indeed we've flipped it so that
academic historians now think their
mission is to travel back to the past
with the value system of 2021 and
castigate
uh the the dead for their racism and
sexism and transphobia and whatnot and
that's exactly wrong
our mission is to go back and try to
understand what it was like to live in
the 18th century
not to go back and condescend to the
the people of the past and once we've
had a better understanding once we've
seen into their lives read their words
tried to reconstitute their experience
to come back
and understand our own time better
that's what we should really be doing
but academic history has gone completely
haywire and it does almost the exact
opposite of what i think it should do
and by studying history
walk beautifully gracefully through this
simulation as you described by mapping
the lessons of history into the world of
today we have virtual reality already in
our heads we do not need oculus
in the metaverse
this was an incredible hopeful
conversation in in many ways that did
not expect i thought our conversation
would be much more about history than
about the future and it turned out to be
the opposite thank you so much for
talking today it's a huge honor to
finally meet you to talk to you thank
you for your valuable time thank you lex
and good luck with putin
you